according to benji when he would go to
those live classes where they would tape
these peloton instructions
hannah corbin she'd have like four
bodyguards standing around her for
creeps like benji
i just tried to say hello to her they
pushed me away
they would announce at the end they
would have bodyguards come up
oh god and they said do not touch the
instructors do not touch the instructors
wow is it an announcement or is it a
voice in your head that's just going on
probably both she's not going out with
you and and she brings up the husband
every minute
i think if i really put my mind to it i
could get anyone
oh that's good for you you don't want to
need
four bodyguards at this place
if i got like really got my life
together my career together and i was
doing [ __ ] awesome i got some i got a
hair
transplant i i could get a lot of women
that's
that's like saying everybody but you're
you
you're you're right now for now i could
get anybody if i completely
change my personality first oh by the
way jen sherman another great instructor
on peloton
peloton jen she was on the wrap-up show
and she commented on benji and she
seemed annoyed by him
and so yeah he would come isn't it funny
he would he would get there on time
to get that freaking bike number seven
right in front
and it's interesting to ride with benji
because benji
doesn't listen to a goddamn thing you
[ __ ] say benji
is riding his own ride he's right in
front of you
and i'm doing fast legs and he's
climbing or i'm climbing and he's doing
fast legs
or we're out of the saddle he's in the
saddle i'm in the saddle he's [ __ ]
out of the saddle
benji she's so right that is so my
experience with you like whatever we're
doing you're doing the opposite what is
that
when i hear a song i love that's when i
can put all my power into it
so that's going by class it's irrelevant
what you know in other words the class
is
the instructor takes you through a
guided tour so that you can get a good
workout
you know what i mean if you want to do
your own thing why go there i found it
very
fun to be around all these people and
these beautiful women
coming on to me while i rode my bike so
it was
it was a fun experience i followed the
beat of my
own chubby drum